after working two years as a developer I
was able to change my domain to cyber
security within my company and recently
I've joined a new organization with a 55
salary hike I was able to change my
domain into something which I'm really
excited about and I think the course
really did help me a lot hey I'm pragya
Patel I'm currently working in cyber
security domain and I really enjoy what
I do I'm originally from MP but I moved
to Mumbai to work with TCS as a
developer right after my graduation but
then I realized I'm interested in cyber
security and I was really curious about
it so I was looking for an online course
because I'm a working professional I
came across an ad on a social media
platform I got interested and researched
about it I decided to go with the
advanced executive program in cyber
security from triple it Bangalore
offered by simply learn I chose this
course because the curriculum was fast
and it had what I wanted to learn while
doing the course I switched to the role
of sock Analyst at TCS I was able to do
so because of the skill sets that I have
acquired in the course recently I
switched to Beta next and I got a 55
salary hike the course prepared me to
change my domain successfully there were
lot of Hands-On projects all the
important topics were covered and the
overall cost really helped me a lot I
learned about malware analysis and
penetration testing which were really
helpful in the fleet I'm really
passionate about cyber security and in
fact I like to research and gather
information about all the ongoing Trends
and tools regarding the same I'm glad
that I discovered my passion and took
steps to achieve it it really motivated
me to take on more risks
[Music]